This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The state of Utah has about 3 million people, and a third of them live in one valley, surrounded on three sides by 7,000 foot mountains into the northwest, by a great salty lake. The valley is home to the state capital, Salt Lake City, and a bunch of other small cities and towns that over time have grown together into one big mass. One of the towns amid the sprawl is Midvale. Okay, we are in Midvale, Utah. Producer Emmett Fitzgerald recently took a trip to Midvale, Utah to visit a mobile home park.
这里是“99%隐形”播客，我是罗曼·马尔斯。犹他州大约有300万人口，其中三分之一居住在一个山谷中。这个山谷三面环绕着7000英尺高的山脉，西北侧则是一个大盐湖。该山谷是州首府盐湖城的所在地，此外还有许多大大小小的城市和小镇，随着时间推移，它们连成了一片广阔的城区。在这些连绵的城区中，有一个名叫米德维尔的小镇。好，我们现在来到了犹他州的米德维尔。制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德最近前往犹他州的米德维尔，去拜访一个移动房屋公园。
I am standing outside of the Applewood community. Applewood is a small mobile home community for seniors. You have to be 55 or older to live there. It's about seven acres with 56 lots and it looks a lot like the rest of suburban Midvale except the houses are smaller and closer together. It has its own little road with its own speed limit, 10 miles per hour. It's a very quiet community, except for that weed locker. And the houses are just a few feet apart, but they all look nice. They're in a really good shape. A little garden's out front of each one.
我正站在苹果木社区的外面。苹果木是一个专门为老年人打造的小型移动房屋社区。你必须年满55岁或以上才能住在那里。这里占地约7英亩，有56个地块，看起来和米德维尔郊区的其他地方很像，只是房子更小、彼此靠得更近。它有自己的小路和专属限速，时速10英里。这是一个非常安静的社区，除了那个杂草储藏室之外。这里的房子相距只有几英尺，但看起来都很好。它们的状况非常棒。每栋房子前面都有一个小花园。
Some daffodils. Let's see, should I use this side entrance or the front entrance? Hello! Hi, I'm here! Thank you. This is Charlene Stoven. She convinced me I needed to come visit Applewood after one phone call. There's something in my voice on the phone that attracts people.
一些水仙花。让我想想，我是该用这个侧门还是正门呢？你好！嗨，我来了！谢谢。这位是查琳·斯托文。她只通过一个电话就说服了我，让我一定要来参观苹果木社区。我电话里的声音似乎有什么特质，很吸引人。
I can get on that phone and I'm not bra breaking but I can get anything I want. I don't know how to do it. Charlene's home is immaculate. She has spotless white carpeting from wall to wall and all this modern furniture that's been carefully color coordinated. And it's really spacious inside. She says that when people first walk in they seem surprised that a mobile home could be so nice. They'll say, this is a home when I'm going, Yeah, it's a manufactured home and it is built stronger and better than 90% of these little track rooms that you find.
我只要打通那个电话——我可不是在吹牛——就能办成我想要的任何事情。我都不知道自己是怎么做到的。查琳的家一尘不染。她铺着从墙到墙的无瑕白地毯，所有的现代家具都经过精心搭配，颜色协调。而且里面空间真的很大。她说，当人们第一次走进来时，似乎都很惊讶移动房屋竟然可以这么漂亮。他们会说：“这居然是个家？”而我会回答：“对啊，这是一栋预制房屋，而且它的建造比你所能找到的90%的小型联排房都要坚固、优质。”
But it's hard for people to get past this tunnel vision of trailers and trailer trash. Mobile homes don't get a lot of love in our culture, but they represent a lot of the affordable housing in the United States. Throughout the 90s, mobile homes made up about two- lot of the affordable housing in the United States. Throughout the 90s, Mobile Homes made up about two-thirds of new affordable housing. Charlene bought her Mobile Homes or manufactured home in 1994. She was divorced. Her kids were grown up and out of the house. She wanted to buy her own place, but she couldn't afford a tracked home in the suburbs. When I thought I was just excited to think,
但人们很难抛开对拖车和“拖车垃圾”的刻板印象。在我们的文化中，移动房屋并不太受待看，但它们在美国的可负担住房中占据了很大一部分比例。在整个90年代，移动房屋约占……在美国，可负担住房中很大一部分都是移动房屋。在整个90年代，移动房屋约占新建可负担住房的三分之二。查琳在1994年购买了她的移动房屋或称预制房屋。当时她已经离婚。她的孩子都已长大成人，搬出了家。她想买一套属于自己的房子，但在郊区买不起联排房。当时我想我只是感到兴奋，因为我觉得……
I can actually now have a beautiful home that I can afford. Those track homes I couldn't afford. I had a borrow money and the loan on the borrowing of the money plus the pad fee was less than what I was paying to rent an apartment. But when you buy a manufactured home, the structure itself is only half of the equation. Then you need to find a place to put it. And Charlene found what seemed like the perfect spot, a small, quiet, mobile home park with an empty lot. When I moved here, I moved to your
我终于可以买起一栋漂亮的房子了。那些联排房我是买不起的。我得借钱，而借钱的贷款再加上车位费，比我租公寓的钱还要少。但当你购买一栋预制房屋时，房屋结构本身只占了一半。接着，你需要找个地方把它安置下来。查琳找到了一个看似完美的地方：一个安静的小型移动房屋公园，里面还有一个空置的地块。“当我搬到这里时，我搬到了……”
February of 1994, I thought I'd died and gone to heaven. I have a little bit of a backyard and I plan a little bit of a garden. My little tomato home, my cucumber, I want just a little bit of a backyard and I plan a little bit of a garden. My little tomato and my cucumber, I want just a little bit of ground and this is just enough, it's perfect. But it wasn't actually perfect. The same dynamic that made this housing situation great for Charlene also made her vulnerable because the mobile home was hers but the land underneath it wasn't. Part of the paradox at the heart of manufactured housing is that it's precisely the thing that makes it so affordable, that also makes this highly insecure form of housing.
1994年2月，我以为自己死后上了天堂。我有一个小小的后院，还开辟了一小块菜园。我的小西红柿，我的黄瓜，我只想要一小块土地，而这刚刚好，简直完美。但实际上并不完美。正是这种让查琳的住房状况变得美好的动态，同时也让她变得脆弱，因为移动房屋是她的，但它底下的土地却不是。预制房屋核心存在的悖论之一在于，正是让它如此实惠的特质，同时也让这种形式的住房变得极度缺乏保障。
This is Esther Sullivan, a sociologist at the University of Colorado, Denver, who studies the relationship between poverty and housing. She says that about a third of mobile homeowners live in parks like Applewood, where they rent a plot of land for their home. She calls this arrangement halfway home ownership because it's filled with all this uncertainty.
这位是科罗拉多大学丹佛分校的社会学家埃丝特·沙利文，她专门研究贫困与住房之间的关系。她说，大约三分之一的移动房屋业主住在像苹果木这样的小区里，在那里他们为自己的房屋租赁一小块土地。她将这种安排称为“半个房主”，因为它充满了各种不确定性。
Residents in parks basically live at the whim of the property owner, where the property owner has the majority of rights in that community. So they are subject to oftentimes poor and shoddy maintenance, ever-increasing rents, and eventually they can be subject to park closure and redevelopment with very little notice. One day in 2011, Shirley came home and found a letter.
公园里的居民基本上是靠产权所有者的慈悲生活，产权所有者在该社区中拥有大部分权利。因此，他们往往要承受糟糕劣质的维护、不断上涨的租金，最终他们还可能面临公园关闭和重新开发，而留给他们的通知时间却非常短。2011年的某一天，雪莉回到家，发现了一封信。
We all received this letter. Your rent is now going up $89 per month and in six months it's going to go up another $89 per month. For decades, the owner of Apple would have taken good care of the park and kept rent slow and affordable, but there were new owners now. And we all went ballistic. Who can afford 89? care of the park and kept rents low and affordable, but there were new owners now. They managed to negotiate the increases down to $70 each, but still in a six month period the rent for each lot went from $320 to $460.
我们所有人都收到了这封信。你的租金现在每月上涨89美元，六个月后还要再涨89美元。几十年来，苹果木的原业主一直把公园照顾得很好，并把租金维持在较低且负担得起的水平，但现在换了新业主。我们所有人都情绪失控了。谁能负担得起89美元的涨幅？……把公园照顾得很好，并把租金维持在较低且负担得起的水平，但现在换了新业主。他们设法将涨幅谈判降至每人70美元，但即便如此，在短短六个月内，每个地块的租金还是从320美元飙升到了460美元。
And rumors started swirling that the increases might just be the first step in a plan to force them out. And so Charlene started digging into what was going on. And pretty soon, she discovered that the new landlord had submitted a plan to the city to build the three-story apartment complex. Right on top of Applewood. Then we understood why they were trying to financially evict us. But Chalene wasn't just going to up and leave.
传言开始四处流传，称这些租金上涨可能只是迫使他们搬走的计划的第一步。于是查琳开始深入调查到底发生了什么。很快，她发现新房东已经向市政府提交了一份计划，准备建造一座三层的公寓大楼。就建在苹果木社区的上方。这时我们才明白他们为什么要从经济上把我们“驱逐”出去。但查琳可不会说走就走。
She'd have to figure something out. Owning your own home has long been seen as a cornerstone of middle class stability in this country. Home ownership helps you build wealth, and as long as you're able to pay your mortgage, you don't have to worry about getting evicted. That security is kind of why we buy houses. But that security just isn't there for many mobile home owners, including Charlene Stovan and the rest of the community at Applewood. We're going to get back to their story in a second, but to understand how mobile home owners ended up in the precarious
她必须想出个对策。在这个国家，拥有自己的房产长期以来一直被视为中产阶级稳定生活的基础。拥有房屋可以帮你积累财富，只要你能还得起房贷，就不用担心被驱逐。这种安全感正是我们买房子的原因。但对于许多移动房屋业主来说，这种安全感根本不存在，其中包括查琳·斯托文和苹果木社区的其他居民。我们马上就会回到他们的故事，但为了理解移动房屋业主是如何陷入拥有房屋却无土地的这种充满不确定性的……
position of owning a home without land, we have to go back to the early 20th century and the dawn of the automobile age. People had cars for the first time and could go out and explore America by attaching little trailers to the backs of their Model T's or whatever cars they had. This is Andrew Hurley, a history professor at the University of Missouri, St. Louis. He says that the first trailer owners were wealthy vacationers, known as Tin Can Tourists. But then came the Great Depression, when migrant workers started living in trailers full time as they traveled the country looking for work. And so there were thousands of itinerant individuals and families in search of work that didn't really know if they would be coming back to where they had originated. And so trailer was something that they could attach
处境中的，我们必须回到20世纪初汽车时代刚刚曙光初现的时期。人们第一次拥有了汽车，并可以通过在福特T型车或其他任何车辆后面挂上小拖车，出门去探索美国。这位是密苏里大学圣路易斯分校的历史学教授安德鲁·赫利。他说，第一批拖车车主是富有的度假者，被称为“铁罐游客”。但随后大萧条降临，随之而来的是寻找工作的农民工开始全职住在拖车里，他们开着车全国各地寻找工作。因此当时有成千上万四处漂泊的个人和家庭在寻找工作，他们其实并不确定自己是否会回到出发的地方。所以拖车就成了他们可以挂在……
to the back of their car and just take their home along with them. And they started to cite these homes together in basically what became the first mobile home parks. These parks were really seen as a major drain on local resources. Writings of the time refer to these as trailer slums. This was the beginning of a kind of classist trailer stigma that is still very much around today. But the event that really solidified the trailer as a viable form of American housing was World War II.
汽车后面，把家随身带着走的东西。他们开始把这些房屋集中停放在基本上成为最早的移动房屋公园的地方。这些公园当时被普遍视为对当地资源的巨大消耗。当时的文字记录将这些地方称为“拖车贫民窟”。这是一场带有阶级色彩的拖车污名化的开始，这种污名化至今依然非常普遍。但真正将拖车巩固为一种可行美式住房形式的事件是第二次世界大战。
the trailer as a viable form of American housing was World War II. American industry has met the challenge of war. American factories have achieved the impossible. American mass production is delivering the goods. As the war got underway, factories popped up in all these remote parts of the country. But because they had been undeveloped, there was no housing. And there was no capacity to build a new housing because construction materials were prioritized for war production. So the government bought thousands of trailers to house the wartime workforce. But this was always supposed to be a temporary solution. When the war ended, the expectation was that people would give up their trailers and move back into conventional homes. But that didn't happen.
……拖车作为一种可行的美式住房形式是第二次世界大战。美国工业迎接了战争的挑战。美国工厂创造了不可能的奇迹。美国的规模化生产正在兑现承诺。随着战争的爆发，工厂在全国各个偏远地区如雨后春笋般涌现。但由于这些地区尚未开发，因此没有住房。而且由于建筑材料被优先用于战时生产，根本没有能力建造新的住房。于是政府购买了数千辆拖车来安置战时劳动力。但这本来应该只是一个临时解决方案。战争结束后，人们预期大家会放弃拖车，搬回传统住宅。但事情并非如此。
Trailers continued to be an affordable housing option for people who didn't have the money to buy a home in the expanding suburbs. And a lot of these mobile homeowners rented pads in one of the many mobile home parks that were popping up all over the country. Esther Sullivan says these parks continued to spread throughout the 60s, 70s and 80s, as the government was investing less and less
对于那些没有钱在不断扩张的郊区买房的人来说，拖车继续是一个负担得起的住房选择。许多这样的移动房屋业主在全国各地如雨后春笋般涌现的众多移动房屋公园里租赁车位。埃丝特·沙利文表示，随着政府对公共住房的投入越来越少，这些公园在60、70和80年代继续蔓延……
in public housing. So just as we've increasingly slashed the budget of HUD and the production of affordable housing. We've seen the incredible rise of manufactured housing and specifically manufactured housing in mobile home parks to fill that gap. Through it all, mobile homes were never really able
因此，正当我们不断削减住房和城市发展部（HUD）的预算以及可负担住房的产量时。我们看到了预制房屋的惊人崛起，特别是移动房屋公园中的预制房屋，它们填补了这一空白。尽管经历了这一切，移动房屋始终无法……
to shake off the stigma that began during the Great Depression. People just did not want mobile Home Parks built in their backyard. In fact, cities used all the tools and the urban planning toolkit to render Mobile Home Parks invisible. For the last half of a century, planning and zoning laws have required that Mobile Home that mobile home parks be walled in, fenced off, visually screened, landscaped out of sight, so that the average citizen in a town or city might not ever know that a park was located where it was located. These parks were often built on marginal land on the outskirts of cities, because mobile
摆脱自大萧条时期开始的污名。人们就是不希望移动房屋公园建在他们的后院。事实上，城市动用了城市规划工具箱中的所有工具，让移动房屋公园变得“隐形”。在过去的半个世纪里，规划和分区法律一直要求移动房屋公园必须被高墙围起、用栅栏隔开、进行视觉遮挡、通过绿化隐于视线之外，好让城镇或城市的普通市民根本不知道某个公园就位于那里。这些公园通常建在城市边缘的边际土地上，因为移动……
homes are legally classified as a form of transportation, rather than housing, they could be built on land that wasn't zoned residential. So separate them from residences and single-family homes, and more often place mobile homes in commercial or industrial zones, as well as in hazarded places like flood plains or substandard land. But as cities develop and expand, mobile home parks become valuable property that can be bought up and redeveloped into something more profitable. A new apartment building, a condo complex, or a Walmart.
房屋在法律上被归类为一种交通工具，而不是住房，因此它们可以建在未划为住宅区的土地上。这样就能把它们与住宅和单户住宅分开，更多时候是将移动房屋安置在商业或工业区，以及诸如洪泛区或劣质土地等危险地点。但随着城市的发展和扩张，移动房屋公园变成了宝贵的财产，可以被收购并重新开发为更有利可图的产业。一个新的公寓大楼、一个共管公寓综合体或一家沃尔玛。
Almost any other land use is prioritized over a mobile home park in the decisions of local city councils and in the eyes of developers and the redevelopment of mobile home parks means mass eviction for mobile home park residents. Which brings us back to mid-Vail Utah and that little mobile home park for seniors where over 50 manufactured homes were on the verge of being evicted to make way for an apartment complex. I asked everyone I met at Applewood if they considered the possibility of redevelopment and eviction when they moved in.
在地方市议会的决策中以及开发商眼中，几乎任何其他土地用途的优先级都高于移动房屋公园，而移动房屋公园的重新开发则意味着对移动房屋公园居民的大规模驱逐。这把我们带回了犹他州米德维尔，带回了那个为老年人开设的小型移动房屋公园，那里有50多栋预制房屋正面临被驱逐的边缘，以为公寓大楼让路。我问了所有我在苹果木遇到的人，当他们搬进来时，是否考虑过重新开发和被驱逐的可能性。
I just hadn't thought about that fact. This is Beth Thurphy. She moved into Applewood with her husband Russell a couple of years ago. I didn't think about the fact that I would have to remove my home or leave my home and having to move out. I never thought that that was possible until they told me that it was. A lot of people, including many developers, assume that if you have victimable home park, the residents will just pick up their houses and move them somewhere else.
我之前根本没有想过这个事实。这位是贝丝·瑟菲。她几年前和丈夫拉塞尔一起搬进了苹果木。“我没有想过我必须搬走我的家或者离开我的家，还得被迫搬迁。我从来没想过这是可能的，直到他们告诉我这是真的。”许多人，包括许多开发商，都认为如果你驱逐一个移动房屋公园，居民们只需收拾好房子，把它搬到其他地方就行了。
But the truth is, mobile homes aren't really mobile anymore. In the mid-20th century, the mobile home industry split in two. One branch continued making travel trailers in RVs, while the other started manufacturing houses designed to be lived in full time. These mobile homes started to look less like trailers and more like conventional single-family houses with multiple rooms and always and in-bore bathrooms, and they got harder and harder to move. Today, the term mobile home is more or less a misnomer. A mobile home is not intended to be mobile except when it is first transported from the factory and installed on the site. And if you try to move it again, it requires specialized trucking and hauling at great expense to homeowners. It can cost between $5,000 and $15,000 to move one of these homes.
但事实是，移动房屋其实已经不再能移动了。在20世纪中叶，移动房屋行业一分为二。一个分支继续制造旅游拖车和房车，而另一个分支则开始制造旨在供人全职居住的房屋。这些移动房屋开始变得不那么像拖车，而更像是带有多个房间、走廊和内置浴室的传统单户住宅，它们变得越来越难移动。今天，“移动房屋”这个词或多或少是一个名不符实的称呼。移动房屋并不打算经常移动，除了它最初从工厂运送到现场并安装好的那一次。如果你想再次移动它，就需要专业卡车和拖运服务，这会给业主带来巨大的开销。搬迁一栋这样的房子可能需要花费5,000到15,000美元。
Moving can also cause serious structural problems. It can damage the homes so severely that it becomes unlivable. And even if residents of Applewood were willing to take that risk and had a spare $15,000 lying around, finding a new place to put their home could be next to impossible. Because there has not been any new manufactured home communities built in Utah for a long, long, long, long time. There's not that many spaces in any of these parks to put 56 homes. This is Charlene Stovan again.
搬迁还会引发严重的结构问题。它可能会对房屋造成严重损坏，使其变得无法居住。即便苹果木的居民愿意冒这个险，并且手头刚好有闲置的15,000美元，想找个新地方安置他们的房子也几乎是不可能的。因为犹他州已经有很长、很长、很长、很长时间没有建造过任何新的预制房屋社区了。在这些公园里，根本没有那么多空间来容纳56栋房子。这位又是查琳·斯托文。
She says that if she got evicted, she would probably have to abandon her home and move in with one of her kids. But some of these people have no family, or their family so far away. Where would they go? Charlene was determined not to let that happen at Applewood, and she talked to some local community organizers who advised her to start a homeowner's association. So our first meeting was at a car park. I can't remember which car park, but one of the car ports here we all met decided this is what we needed to do to save ourselves.
她说，如果她被驱逐了，她可能不得不抛弃自己的房子，搬去和她的某个孩子住在一起。但这些人当中，有些人没有家人，或者家人远在天边。他们能去哪里呢？查琳决心不让这种事在苹果木发生，她咨询了一些当地的社区组织者，他们建议她成立一个业主协会。所以我们的第一次会议是在停车场开的。我不记得是哪个停车场了，但我们大家就在这里的其中一个车棚开会，决定这就是我们必须采取的行动，以拯救我们自己。
And I of course became president. Of course. Will P and I thought okay, what do, became president. Of course. Will be. And I thought, OK, what do I do now? I'm clueless. But she kept asking people for help. And little by little, they started rallying people to their cause. The residents started a petition to save Applewood
而我理所当然地成了会长。当然啦。威利·P和我心想，好吧，现在该怎么做，成了会长。当然啦。会是……我想，好吧，现在我该做什么？我一无所知。但她不断向人们寻求帮助。渐渐地，他们开始动员人们加入他们的事业。居民们发起了一份拯救苹果木的请愿书……
and got over 2,600 signatures. Charlene testified before the mayor and the city council and told them, if we allow this guess what? You're going to have 56 homeowners that will be homeless. And what are you going to do with us? Homelessness is a huge problem in Utah right now. And it's been exacerbated by a housing shortage. And apartment complexes are going up all over the Salt Lake Valley to try and meet a growing demand.
收集了2600多人的签名。查琳在市长和市议会面前作证，告诉他们：“如果我们允许这件事发生，你们猜怎么着？你们将会有56位业主无家可归。那你们打算怎么对待我们？”无家可归目前是犹他州的一个大问题。而这个问题又因住房短缺而雪上加霜。盐湖谷各地都在兴建公寓大楼，以满足不断增长的需求。
Charlene says that's good. You need the apartment's freight, build them, but don't displace people in order to do it. Charlene and the other residents of Applewood fought for several years to stay in their homes. There were a lot of twists and turns and late nights and a whole lot of emails, but eventually, after a lot of public pressure, the development company gave up on the project and decided to put Applewood up for sale. And when Shirley and her that, she remembered an organization that she thought might be able to help them out.
查琳说这很好。你需要公寓，那就建吧，但不要为了建公寓而让人们流离失所。查琳和苹果木的其他居民为留在自己的家园奋斗了好几年。这期间经历了许多转折、无数个不眠之夜以及大量的电子邮件，但最终，在强大的公众舆论压力下，开发公司放弃了这个项目，并决定将苹果木挂牌出售。当雪莉听到这个消息时，她想起了一个她认为可能会提供帮助的组织。
It was called ROC USA. Yeah, so ROC stands for resident-owned communities, and we help homeowners in mobile home parks by their communities as co-ops. This is Paul Bradley, the president of Rock USA, which is based in New Hampshire. Bradley began organizing mobile home co-ops with the New Hampshire Community Loan Fund back in the 80s. They even got legislation passed in New Hampshire that gives mobile home owners a first option to purchase the land whenever a park goes up for sale. Today, about 27% of the manufactured home communities are Mobile Home Parks and New Hampshire
它叫做ROC USA。是的，ROC代表居民所有制社区（Resident-Owned Communities），我们通过帮助移动房屋公园的业主以合作社形式购买他们的社区。这位是保罗·布拉德利，总部位于新罕布什尔州的Rock USA的总裁。布拉德利早在80年代就开始与新罕布什尔州社区贷款基金合作组织移动房屋合作社。他们甚至在新罕布什尔州推动通过了一项立法，赋予移动房屋业主在公园挂牌出售时购买土地的优先购买权。如今，新罕布什尔州约有27%的预制房屋社区和移动房屋公园属于居民所有，也就是大约127个社区。
are resident owned, so that's 127 or so communities. Bradley thinks we need to build more affordable housing, but he also wants to protect the affordable housing we already have. Right now, Mobile Home's represent the largest source of unsubsidized affordable housing produced in this country. Bradley says that if we can help Mobile Homes owners buy the land beneath their parks, then the risk of massive action disappears. And so in 2008, Bradley launched Rocky USA in an effort to spread New Hampshire's cooperative ownership model nationwide. So far, they've been really successful.
布拉德利认为我们需要建造更多可负担住房，但他也希望保护我们已经拥有的可负担住房。目前，移动房屋代表了这个国家产生的最大规模的无补贴可负担住房来源。布拉德利说，如果我们能帮助移动房屋业主购买公园底下的土地，那么大规模驱逐的风险就会消失。因此，在2008年，布拉德利创立了Rocky USA，旨在将新罕布什尔州的合作所有权模式推广到全国。到目前为止，他们取得了巨大的成功。
So we're a national network of just over 220 communities, 14,000 home owners, and we're operating with co-ops in 15 states. When Charlene called Paul, Pratley, things were not looking good for Applewood. The land had already been sold to two new developers for $4.8 million. But Sherleenan Paul approached the new owners and explained the situation. They talked about how difficult it would be to move their homes and asked if the new owners would be willing to sell the park to the residents. And they said, we didn't realize you wanted to purchase the property,
所以我们是一个由220多个社区、14,000名业主组成的全国性网络，我们在15个州运营着合作社。当查琳打电话给保罗·布拉德利时，苹果木的情况可不容乐观。这块土地已经以480万美元的价格卖给了两个新开发商。但查琳和保罗找到新业主并向他们解释了情况。他们谈到了搬迁房屋的艰难程度，并询问新业主是否愿意将公园卖给居民。他们说：“我们没意识到你们想买这块地，……”
but if you want to and you can do it within the next couple of months, we'll sell it to you. Otherwise, if we're gonna if we're gonna own it, eventually we're gonna close it down. Buying a mobile home park worth at least $4.8 million seemed like a very tall order for the residents of Applewood. Individually, no one in the park could even come close to getting a mortgage for that kind of money. But together as a co-op, the financial picture was different. Rock USA was willing to give the residents a very low interest loan for $3.6 million. They would still need to find some more money, though, and so they went to a low-income housing
但如果你想买，而且能在接下来的几个月内搞定，我们就把它卖给你。否则，如果我们自己拥有它，最终我们还是会把它关掉。对于苹果木的居民来说，买下一个价值至少480万美元的移动房屋公园似乎是一个极其艰巨的任务。单凭个人之力，公园里的任何人甚至都无法凑齐买这种数额房产的抵押贷款。但作为一个合作社团结起来，财务状况就完全不同了。Rock USA愿意向居民提供一笔360万美元的极低利息贷款。不过他们仍然需要筹集更多资金，于是他们去找了一个低收入住房……
for a new talk called the O'Lean Walker Housing Loan Fund. So there I am again. Pleading my case, and Gloria, who is the director said I thought about this the last three months and I've decided we need to help these people we need to give them the money they need so between it all we finally come up with the five million that we needed and our February 9th we signed for we own the land. After four and a half years of fighting for their little piece of ground the land officially belongs to the Applewood Homeowners Cooperative.
一个名为奥林·沃克住房贷款基金（O'Lean Walker Housing Loan Fund）的项目。于是我又出场了。我极力陈述我们的诉求，担任主任的格洛丽亚说：“过去三个月我一直在考虑这件事，我决定我们必须帮助这些人，我们必须给他们所需的资金。”因此通过各方努力，我们终于凑齐了所需的500万美元，并在2月9日正式签约，我们拥有了这块土地。经过四年半为自己的一小块土地而战，这块土地正式属于了苹果木业主合作社。
To pay off their collective mortgage the residents agreed to pay $60 more a month than they had previously been paying in rent. It's going to be a challenge for some of them but the monthly cost should be stable from here on out, and they'll no longer need to worry about a fiction. We can breathe again. I had to worry about losing our home and everything we had in it. I know we can own our home and feel at ease. This is Russell Durphy, who lives in Applewood with his wife Beth, who you heard from earlier.
为了偿还集体的抵押贷款，居民们同意每月比以往的租金多付60美元。这对其中一些人来说将是一个挑战，但从今以后每月的费用应该会保持稳定，他们再也不需要担心被驱逐了。我们可以重新呼吸了。我不得不担心失去我们的家以及里面的一切。我知道我们可以拥有自己的家并感到安心。这位是拉塞尔·瑟菲，他和妻子贝丝（你刚才听过她的声音）一起住在苹果木。
He says that at their age, they're just happy to have a secure place to live. We're getting so old and feeble that we don't know how much longer we're going to live, so when we go grocery shopping, we don't even buy a green banana. You can never get enough Joe, get out of here. Charlene is also relieved, but the stress hasn't gone away completely. They own the place now. They've got a co-op to run, and bills to pay. Before, it was fighting to gain the land. Now, it's a whole different set of pressures of just getting this running smoothly.
他说，在他们这个年纪，能有一个安全的地方居住就已经很高兴了。我们年纪越来越大、越来越虚弱，不知道自己还能活多久，所以当我们去杂货店购物时，我们甚至不买绿色的香蕉。你永远也听不够乔的唠叨，走开吧。查琳也松了一口气，但压力并没有完全消失。他们现在拥有这个地方了。他们有一个合作社要运营，还有账单要付。以前是为争取土地而战，现在则是面对让这一切顺利运转的一套全新的压力。
And the co-op is a different ball game. Because now we're in charge. It's up to us to make it work. Otherwise, we're in deep, deep, do-do. But they aren't on their own. Rock USA is helping them structure the co-op and deal with the finances. And of course, a cooperative Applewood means cooperative living.
而合作社是完全不同的另一码事。因为现在由我们当家作主了。一切都得靠我们自己让它运作起来。否则，我们就要陷入极大的麻烦之中了。但他们并不是孤军奋战。Rock USA正在帮助他们构建合作社并处理财务问题。当然，苹果木的合作社意味着合作生活。
There are lots of meetings and elections, committees, more committees. There's the community rules enforcement committee. There's the finance committee. There's the orientation committee. There's the maintenance committee. There's the social committee. These are all committees we're trying to get organized.
这里有许多会议和选举、委员会、更多的委员会。有社区规则执行委员会。有财务委员会。有迎新委员会。有维护委员会。有社会委员会。这些都是我们正试图组织起来的委员会。
Russell Durfy says he's not well enough to participate as much as he would like, but he went to the first general meeting of the co-op and he was really impressed. They asked for volunteers to be president, vice president, so forth, and in every position they had volunteers. They didn't have to coach people, the servos leaders, they just automatically volunteered to do it. Russell says they have lots of different skills
拉塞尔·瑟菲说，他身体状况不够好，无法像自己希望的那样多参与，但他参加了合作社的第一次全体会议，并留下了深刻的印象。他们征求志愿者担任会长、副会长等等，而且每一个职位都有人自愿报名。他们不需要说服别人，这些未来的领导者们只是自动自发地报名去做。拉塞尔说，他们拥有许多不同的技能……
and decades of experience here in Applewood. And they're trying to take advantage of everyone's talents. The head of the Maintenance Committee, for example, is a retired engineer. Our secretary is kind of automatic. She was a secretary for a retired engineer. Our secretary is kind of automatic. She was a secretary for a police department. I ask her how she could possibly list and have a fast get all the notes down and so forth. I did it for many years. The co-op is going to be a
在苹果木这里有着几十年的经验。他们正试图充分利用每个人的才华。例如，维护委员会的负责人是一名退休工程师。我们的秘书可以说是顺理成章。她曾是一名警察局的秘书。我问她怎么可能一边听一边快速记下所有的笔记等等。我做过很多年这个。这个合作社将会有……
lot of work but at least for now people are glad to be part of it, and to finally own the land under their homes. Together. Esther Sullivan, the sociologist we spoke to for this story, has a new book out later this year. It's called Manufactured Insecurity, mobile home parks and Americans tenuous right to place. Sheddy lived in several mobile home parks that were undergoing eviction and studied the impacts. You can find a link to the book on our website 99pi.org.
很多工作要做，但至少目前，大家很高兴能成为其中一员，并且终于拥有了自己房屋底下的土地。共同拥有。埃斯特·沙利文，我们为这个故事采访的社会学家，今年晚些时候将出版一本新书。书名是《制造的不安全感：移动房屋公园与美国人脆弱的居住权》（Manufactured Insecurity: Mobile Home Parks and American's Tenuous Right to Place）。她曾居住在几个正经历驱逐的移动房屋公园并研究了其影响。你可以在我们的网站99pi.org上找到该书的链接。
The ever evolving design of mobile homes and the concept of mobile home skyscrapers, right after this. When Emmett was reporting this story, he discovered all the different names for these things, and that they were used interchangeably but also had different meanings for different people, terms like trailer, manufactured home, mobile home, and Cole Stead is here to talk about the rise of the term mobile home, and how that design evolved over time. Right, and Emma was telling me that when he was interviewing people
移动房屋不断演变的设计以及移动房屋摩天大楼的概念，广告之后马上回来。当埃米特在做这个故事的报道时，他发现了这些东西的所有不同名称，它们既可以互换使用，但对不同的人来说又有着不同的含义，比如拖车、预制房屋、移动房屋等术语，科尔·斯蒂德将在这里谈论移动房屋这个词的崛起，以及它的设计是如何随时间演变的。没错，埃米特告诉我，当他在采访时……
for the story, like everybody was just using a different term for sort of the same thing. And this actual term mobile home, according to Stewart Brand's really excellent book, How Buildings Learn, was actually coined by a man named Elmer Frey. And I haven't been able to verify that independently, but Frey did play a big role in popularizing it, if nothing else. And he's this really interesting character. In the 40s, he started a mobile home manufacturing business in Wisconsin. And he sold a lot of these eight-foot wide homes
为了这个故事，每个人都在用不同的词来指代大致相同的东西。而根据斯图尔特·布兰德那本非常优秀的著作《建筑物如何学习》（How Buildings Learn）记载，这个实际的词“移动房屋”实际上是由一个叫埃尔默·弗雷（Elmer Frey）的人创造的。我没能独立核实这一点，但不管怎样，弗雷在普及这个词方面确实发挥了巨大作用。他是一个非常有趣的人物。在40年代，他在威斯康星州创办了一家移动房屋制造企业。他销售了许多这种8英尺宽的房屋……
But he also lobbied to be able to transport 10 foot wides on public roads and what is the big difference between an eight-foot wide home and a 10-foot wide home Those two feet so if you think about a typical mobile home at the time the real limitation is that horizontal dimension You can make one that's dozens of feet long But it's really hard to fit in, walls and a hallway if it's too thin. So if you add a few feet of width, you can suddenly subdivide space, create rooms, and connect them via a side corridor. So now you can walk past these fully enclosed individual spaces rather than always stepping through one room to get to another. And that means you've got privacy and you can fit a family more comfortably.
但他也游说政府允许在公共道路上运输10英尺宽的房屋。8英尺宽的房屋和10英尺宽的房屋之间有什么大区别呢？就是那两英尺。因此，如果你想想当时的典型移动房屋，真正的局限性在于那个水平尺寸。你可以造一个几十英尺长的房子……但如果它太窄，就很难容纳墙壁和走廊。因此，如果你增加几英尺的宽度，你突然就可以划分空间、创建房间，并通过侧面走廊将它们连接起来。所以现在你可以走过这些完全封闭的个人空间，而不必总是穿过一个房间才能进入另一个房间。这意味着你拥有了隐私，并且可以更舒适地容纳一个家庭。
Some builders would also make ones that would expand on site to become wider. And then of course you've got your double-wides and your triple-wides designed to be joined together on site. And as you make these leaps, it sounds like my wall home is already coming less and less mobile, actually. Exactly.
一些建筑商还会制造在现场展开变宽的房屋。当然，还有专为在现场拼接而成的“双宽”和“三宽”房屋。随着你实现这些跨越，听起来我的墙面房屋其实已经越来越不“移动”了。完全正确。
As 10 wides and then 12 wides gained popularity, they were increasingly created to just be shipped out, set down and lived in. And for HUD, you know, the US Department of Housing and Urban Development, this posed a problem. A lot of these, relatively immobile homes, were not being constructed to the same standards as normal lot built houses. So in the mid 1970s, Congress passed the Mobile Home Construction and Safety Standards Act, which basically was to make sure that new manufactured homes would be more energy efficient and disaster resistant. What did those regulations do to the industry and the mobile home housing stock? Well, the new HUD codes set standards for things like safety and durability, but also heating,
随着10英尺宽和后来的12英尺宽房屋越来越受欢迎，它们越来越多地被直接运出、安放并居住。对于美国住房和城市发展部（HUD）来说，这带来了一个问题。许多这些相对固定的房屋并没有按照与普通地块建造房屋相同的标准进行建造。因此在20世纪70年代中期，国会通过了《移动房屋建设和安全标准法案》，该法案的基本目的是确保新型预制房屋更具能源效率和抗灾能力。这些法规对该行业和移动房屋住房存量产生了什么影响？好吧，新的HUD法规为安全性、耐用性以及供暖等各方面设定了标准……
plumbing, ventilation, air conditioning, electrical systems. All those things you normally associate with regional building codes, but that didn't always apply to mobile homes. And from a federal standpoint, this is where that manufactured homes distinction comes in. Predictably, of course, some people in the business of producing prefab homes weren't exactly pleased with the added layer of regulations, I don't say. But, you know, the new rules did lead to better design and stir your construction.
管道、通风、空调、电气系统。所有这些你通常与地区建筑规范联系在一起，但并不总是适用于移动房屋的事物。从联邦的角度来看，这就是“预制房屋”这一区别的由来。当然，可以预见的是，一些从事预制房屋生产的人对这层新增的法规并不是很满意，这是肯定的。但是，新规则确实带来了更好的设计和更坚固的结构。
So you mentioned Stuart Brands book, How Building Slurn, which is all about the ways that buildings evolve and adapt over time. But it seems to me that whatever you call these types of homes, they're basically kind of free design self-contained, and they're not really designed to change over time. Yeah, in a way that's true. They don't have to change over time. You know, the factory
所以你提到了斯图尔特·布兰德的书《建筑物如何学习》，该书专门探讨了建筑物随时间演变和适应的方式。但在我看来，不管你如何称呼这些类型的房屋，它们基本上都是预先设计好的独立单元，并不是真正设计用来随时间改变的。是的，在某种程度上确实如此。它们不需要随时间而改变。你知道，工厂……
builds it, ships it out, sets down, plugs it in, and it's good to go. But brand points out that these initial modules are actually rich with potential too. As he puts it, a smaller unit can become the quote seed around which a larger home grows. So for instance, an owner might build out a shed roof to create a porch, and then eventually enclose that on all sides to create interior space. So for someone who can't afford a house right away, or a big house at least, this kind of base model approach allows owners to build out on their own terms when they have the time and the budget. Of course, this is also tied up in that increasing in mobility of the manufacturer to housing too, right? Once you start expanding this thing.
建造它，运出去，放下，接通电源，就可以直接使用了。但布兰德指出，这些初始模块其实也充满了潜力。正如他所说，一个较小的单元可以成为“种子”，围绕它生长出一栋更大的房子。例如，业主可能会搭建一个棚顶来创建一个门廊，然后最终将四周封闭起来以创造室内空间。因此，对于无法立刻买起房子（或者至少是大房子）的人来说，这种基本模型的方法允许业主在有时间和预算的时候，按照他们自己的条件进行扩建。当然，这也与预制房屋日益固定的属性息息相关，对吧？一旦你开始扩建这个东西。
They're there to stay. Yeah. And so what about Frey, the original mobile home popularizer? Is a builder and seller of these kinds of structures? What was his reaction to the shift from mobile homes to these immobile manufactured houses? So he ended up exploring some pretty extreme ideas in the 1960s and 70s, while HUDs over
它们就在那里扎根了。是的。那么最初普及移动房屋的弗雷呢？作为这类结构的建造者和销售者，他对从移动房屋向这些无法移动的预制房屋的转变有什么反应？所以他在60和70年代最终探索了一些相当极端的想法，当HUD这边在制定标准时，弗雷实际上是在为移动房屋提议建造摩天大楼。他早期的计划之一是在密尔沃基竖立两座螺旋形塔楼，每座塔楼都有数百个供便携式住宅停放的车位。这些塔楼在停车/居住区的上方和下方还将设有餐厅、商店和社区空间。所以也许你住上几年，拉起手刹，把你的家开到另一个城市的下一个移动摩天大楼公园，在那里你找到了一份新工作。在每一个地方，你都将生活在一个适合步行的市中心。
here developing standards, Frey is actually proposing skyscrapers for mobile homes. And one of his early plans was to erect these two spiraling towers in Milwaukee, each with hundreds of parking spaces for portable dwellings. And those towers would also have restaurants and shops and community spaces above and below the parking slash living areas. So maybe you stay for a few years, pull up the parking brake, and roll your home to the next mobile skyscraper park in another city where you get a new job. And in each place, you'd be living in a walkable downtown.
这让人想起《头号玩家》（Ready Player One），主角住在那些层层叠叠的移动房屋堆栈里。是的。看起来确实不怎么好看。不，我的意思是，它们确实有点缺乏吸引力。坦率地说，弗雷制作的原型只有几层楼高，基本上也就是那个样子。它们并没有那么吸引人，而且实际效果也不好。
And that's reminiscent of Ready Player One where the main character lives and the stacks were these stacks and stacks of mobile houses. Yeah. Which don't really look all that nice exactly. No, I mean, they're really kind of not very appealing. And frankly, the prototypes that Frey made, they were just a couple stories tall, and they basically looked like that. And they weren't that appealing, and they didn't work that well.
它们并没有那么吸引人，而且实际效果也不好。
But his larger vision of these really tall towers was actually pretty interesting, if you think about it. If it had worked out, his so-called skyscraper terrace could have brought mobile housing right into the heart of cities and combined mobility with urban density in a really unprecedented way. Well, you can see pictures of phrase-proposed skyscraper terrace and other vertical mobile housing designs on our website, it's 99pi.org. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, musicouffman, Taren Masa, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Roe in Beautiful,
不过，仔细想想，他关于这些超高层建筑的宏大构想其实相当有趣。如果行得通的话，他所谓的摩天大楼露台本来可以把移动住宅直接带入城市中心，以一种空前绝后的方式将移动性与城市密度结合起来。嗯，你可以在我们的网站 99pi.org 上看到皮尔斯提出的摩天大楼露台及其他垂直移动住宅设计的图片。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，还有库夫曼、塔伦·马萨以及我，罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 电台的一个项目，在美丽的美丽广播罗伊制作，
Downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, an independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI orc, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you're thinking, I need more 99PI in my life. Well, we have all the old episodes and new articles about design
加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。99% Invisible 是来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia 成员，PRX 是播客界最具创新性节目的独立集合体。请访问 radiotopia.fm 查找所有这些节目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，或@节目账号 99PI orc，也可以在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上找到我们。但如果你在想，我的生活中需要更多的 99PI。嗯，我们在我们精美的网站上每隔几天就会发布所有旧节目和关于设计的新文章
every couple of days on our beautiful website. It's 99pi.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 99pi.org。来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia。本集暂时还没有评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。